e
Alo announce if I'm going uh if I'm
going rogue I'll always announce that
all right I'm going to uh call our work
session um on S SP
437 um we had a discussion last time we
were in subcommittee on this one and uh
a few issues that we kind of wanted to
look at um I've looked into those issues
um and my personal feeling is the bill
is pretty well written um and we should
just pass it as it is um I'll open it up
to the sub if you have any other
thoughts or concerns about taking that
direction if you'd like to go a
different way with
it I know I talked with Peter about it
he's fine with it as well he's just not
in here at the moment for the so um if
that's the case I would entertain a
motion onb
437 yes representative void ought to
pass on on 437 ought to pass by
representative voyd second by
Me seconded by representative Schmidt
all right any uh further
discussion all in favor all right we'll
close the work session on 437 and we'll
bring that recommendation to the
committee and uh to all my Democrat
colleagues uh I guess we're caucusing in
here so we'll see you guys in about half
an hour no I understand and everybody in
the audience as well with us we're
caucusing so we'll have to clear the
[Laughter]
drink all
doing
e
morning all right we have two
substitutes here representative Melvin
is in for representative
aaso and representative Schulz is in for
representative
O'Brien right and representative Gard is
on his way I'm
sure um we have two early bills that we
need to get out and I think we should
take care of those
439 I'm going to move and expedient to
legislate
okay and I'll start by saying
that we have always this committee has
opposed using the state's purchasing
power or investment
power
for
political
um well in this case political posturing
for a long long time this bill
forbids uh discriminating boycotts of
Israel and
it's actually ineffective because
there's an executive order that prevents
any of the executive agencies from doing
so this bill would not apply to the
treasurer nor the um retirement system
because they're not executive agencies
so it doesn't apply to anybody and it is
purely put in as a making a statement so
I'm opposed representative Schmidt thank
you madam chair uh I agree with your
statement uh also I think that uh when
when the testimony in in presenting the
bill to us was offered uh the state the
the the language well the statement was
made that this is codifying the governor
prior executive order right and I asked
the question and some of you were there
at the time may recall I said has
anything
happened since that executive order was
issued that might influence a different
take on what's going on uh with regard
to a boycott and so forth and so on um
and he kind of finessed the answer but
the bottom line is in the meantime we've
had six months of um a very destructive
campaign in Gaza um which I think uh
that that's the thing that people are
very upset
about the the dying the death the
killing the destruction that's going on
in Gaza and the and that has nothing to
do in my opinion with a legitimate right
of people to protest that at those
actions it has nothing to do with a
legitimate right to disagree with the
with the executive actions of the
Israeli government that's not the same
as being anti-semitic but the but the
language of the bill refers to
anti-Semitism repeatedly that's not what
this is about and so forth so I think
this this bill does not work and not not
appropriate and I wholehearted
endorse the idea of voting itl thank you
representative
leus thank you um I'm going to support
the itl uh what I'd like to say is my
vote has nothing to do with my views
which I have on the situation the Middle
East actions of Israel or Palestinians
and all of that I just don't want to see
the procurement system uh being
influenced by whatever the political
Winds of the day are and um it should in
my view it has one and only one job and
that's to get the best deals for the
taxpayers of New Hampshire in uh you
know any purchasing Contracting or
whatever so that's my reason for
supporting it separate from anything
that okay anyone else representative
Dolan thank you madam chair I uh I'm not
going to support the the the itl uh
although I I agree with the position of
the chair that this uh procurement
system should not be contaminated with
these types of things but I I I don't
want to be misconstrued somehow that
that was sending a me a message of
support to uh to Hamas and and their
activity so I'm going to be voting
against the
itl all
right okay anyone else represents Simon
thank you madam chair just briefly yes I
I won't be supporting the itl either
although I do 99.9% of the time um agree
with the position that you've intimated
uh and I've struggled with this one
honestly I see the arguments on both
sides um I making the call last minute
because I was on the fence uh right up
until now um and I guess I land here
simply because yes we don't typically
deal with intern International Affairs
um but our f federal government who does
deal in international Affairs has taken
a position on this and they continue to
support um Israel it's an ally of ours
who is at this point whether you agree
with it or not which I I respect
people's um ability to have their
opinion on on what's going on what's
right and what's not right um but they
are in a state of war and so for people
within our country to be boycotting an
ally of ours who are in a state of War
just doesn't seem like a precedent we
want to set either so for that reason I
won't be able to the itl even though yes
almost always I would I would fall in
made okay anyone
else yes rent gold thank you madam chair
I just want to briefly say that uh my
vote will be in support of itl because
of the uh responsibility it would put on
our procurement officers to try to
understand what the politics of various
corporations are it can be very
complicated my person personal views are
um are what they are and they support
who they support but I just don't see
that tangling up with what we require
our procurement people to do in the
divis in the
state representative
Brown uh thank you madam chair as you
know I will not be supporting itl and I
think probably a representative Simon
and Dolan probably already said uh where
I uh where I stand on that issue um I I
would like to comment uh repent Schmidt
I I always appreciate and respect what
you say at at at Great length and and I
thank you I don't think
that listening to the testimony there
were certainly ought to talk about the
the current happenings in the Middle
East but the boycott devest uh
divestment and sanctions
policy to impact Israel has been in
place long before October 7th and so I
don't look at it that me being concerned
about the boycott process has anything
to do with October 7th aside from where
representative Simon went so thank you
madam
chair anyone
else all right seeing none the motion is
inexpedient to legislate and the clerk
can call the role representative Simon
no representative lakas yes
representative
Bailey
no represent
Dolan represent ghard yes clerk votes no
represent Boyd
no represented Brown no representative
gr yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative gold yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes and the chair
yes 14 y six
nay all right motion passes 14 to6 it
will be on the regular calendar is
Report I guess not okay
excuse me Ron Brown you're writing a
Minority Report well I wasn't really
volunteering but it seems like one of us
should do that I would
think at a as six people voted for it so
uh I guess yeah I am so you're you are
volunteering for that but I guess
you and uh committee reports are due
today so start writing
which is why I didn't
[Laughter]
volunteer okay that's the first of the
early bills the second one is Senate
Bill
480 and representative grota you have a
a
motion I do I'd like to move
I
am
motion
480 what was the amendment number again
please um
so the amendment um this this um bill
went to
subcommittee and um it refers to the
real estate Practice Act and
specifically refer um adds a what
postlicensing what that what that
definition is and per the
um board we um they asked for a time
change of February 1st 2024 rather than
February 1st
2020 and that was the um amendment made
in committee
yes it I'd like to mention that this
amendment deletes the sections we had
some issues with like the single person
for each of the larger
um the larger boards are not supporting
themselves very well the
um the the fees are in the process of
being
readjusted and so we don't quite know
how much each board will have available
for extra
um but I thought that made a lot of
sense and also
director Courtney was concerned that
having one person dedicated to each
board would create a single point of
failure because that person would do
everything and nobody else would know
how things ran or how to answer the
questions and so she
was she was opposed to the idea
particularly it being
mandated if it turns out that it is a
good idea to have a dedicated person or
two for one of the larger boards that's
well within the opl's authority to
there all right any questions man py
thank you madam chair just a quick
question looks like the amendment
replaces the entire
Bill am I correct representative
gr yes you might remember that in the
bill we had for sections and we said we
were going to adopt two of
else okay that case the motion is to
adopt Amendment 1568 H to Senate Bill
480 and the clerk and call the war
representative Simon yes represent lakus
yes representative Bailey yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Dolan yes representative geard yes Clerk
yes representative boydd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representa representative
Schultz yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative gold yes representative
Smith yes representative Manti yes and
the chair yes 20 a0 a
okay representing PR
I move a to pass with as amended on
right right do you need to speak to your
motion I don't believe so I think we
discussed most of it with the discussion
on the amendment okay sh
it I'll just say that basically with the
amendment this is what uh
Mr Quinn from the board requested so I
think we're making everyone
happy oh what a marvelous idea if that
were to be the
that exactly anyone else have a comment
question okay in that case the motion is
to for Senate Bill 480 ought to pass
with Amendment let can call the
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Dolan yes representative Gard yes clerk
vote Yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groda yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative
G yes representative Smith yes
representative Manti yes and the chair
yes 20 a0 n all right motion passes 20
to Zer does anyone have an objection to
consent the bill as amended takes out
the the expense so I think it's small
enough to go on
consent no objection we'll put it on
bill but they won't have much to
and okay let's try Senate Bill
437 since we've got several people here
Simon uh thank you madam chair the
subcommittee took a look at this um bill
and we are moving a to pass is there a
second
I'll
second representative Dolan was
okay representative Simon you wish to
speak to your motion um yeah so there
were a lot of moving Parts on this bill
um and so uh we were able to take a bit
of a deeper dive in the subcommittee uh
meeting and um as such I was able to
gain a greater understanding of the
language and and how it's been
constructed um to kind of address the
concerns that were brought up during the
initial public hearing ing um one of the
things that really kind of clarified
things for me was language changes
throughout uh in present RSA the words
were provision and regulations now
they're amendments meaning that uh if
you're going to make a change to the
building code uh you have to amend a
code that's actually been adopted by um
the state um board and uh so uh kind of
just looking down through the
bill um basically what it uh prevents
from happening is on the um municipal
level uh keeps individual municipalities
from adopting wholesale code that hasn't
been approved by the building code
review board or basically um adopting
full code by a Thousand Cuts uh just
doing a thousand different changes to
try to get to a new code it basically
prohibits those two things um and the
reason for that is is basically uh for
consistency across the state the fear is
that uh um without this um people who
are doing work throughout the state
won't know from one municipality to
another you know what the rules are for
that particular municipality and uh it
really would just undermine the idea of
having a building code review board at
all so basically just says that if you
um want to have a rule that's more
stringent uh than one that the uh
building code review board at the state
level has adopted um that just needs to
come uh to the building code review
board at the state level uh to be looked
at and to be confirmed uh that it meets
the criteria um and if it hasn't gone to
the building code review board Within 60
days and and um had that confirmation
happen then it's not um effective on the
state level it can't be um so what I'm
looking for enforced enforced thank you
it can't be enforced on the local level
so it would give um private citizens a
right to civil uh civil action um if a
town was trying to enforce a code um
that would had not gone through the
legal process um I've been told by
Council and our own Council that yes it
would give a a right to civil action um
by an individual uh in in the State uh
to recoup the added expense that wasn't
um legally put in place so uh thought it
was in the end thought it was pretty
well written and uh uh made sense to us
so that's why I move OTP okay Dolan do
second I think the vice
chair coined well so I'm in support of
us repr Brown thank you madam chair so
to representative assignment for me to
be clear which apparently is hard
sometimes the some of the concern about
this was what you said that there would
be towns that would have
differing building codes per town and
what you just said they will only be
able to ask for an amendment to the
State Building Code but will if I
understood what you just said will that
then be that
Town's piece of the building code or
will that change the entire state code I
no it would just it would just adjust it
within that municipality I mean it does
a few other things too it's a it's a
there's a lot in the bill um it would
allow them to look at other National
codes uh and adopt some code that isn't
addressed by the State Building Code so
there are some things that our building
code doesn't address they can adopt
those things on the local level as well
um but yes it would just be effective in
their town but it has to be attached to
they have to to be amending a code that
has already been adopted by the state
building code and then passed through
the legislature they can't just go
willy-nilly at it okay and follow up
sorry it also means that a local
Amendment will be reviewed by the
building code review board who
understands it and it will be publicized
so that everybody
knows which I which has been a problem
you pres G hark thank you just quick
question how is it publicized how how
will it be
publicized it will be on the building
code Review Board website along with the
State Building Code okay and presumably
if a town adopts an amendment they'll
have it in their town office along with
their copy of the building
code okay thank you m I'm sure um yeah
one of the other reasons for the bill is
it is a they wanted to basically have a
clearing house where any codes and
amendments to codes in different
municipalities would all be located in
the same spot so if you had a question
you could go to the State Building Code
you know website uh for that town find
out what the amended codes are and you
would know where you're looking so that
it's not you know a question right now
because it's not going through the
building code review board all over the
time it's not necessarily being posted
there you could go into municipality and
it's your word against theirs without
doing some real research as to and
whether or not that town or municipality
um adopted the code through the legal
process did they go through an ordinance
did they you know did they do all that
work or is it just the local enforcement
agency basically saying well this is the
way that I want it to be so that's what
you're going to do
else okay seeing none representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so we're
heading in the direction of a more
knowledgeable and informed
process uh in terms of this the inter
inter ational and National
standards uh and having an an expert uh
board building
called review board the chairman is with
us this
morning and uh and so that's to the good
because it was more halfhazard before
and you had situations in some
localities where ordinances were being
adopted in an in in an illegal fashion
where there was no real legality to it
and that should not be possible um and
this is this is one of the things that
this would get rid of um so this is
definitely a step in the right direction
in terms of giving localities more of a
handle on the way that things need to be
done and more confidence in the the the
uh standards that are being promulgated
because they've been reviewed by the
building code review board before they
propagated at a state level and a
locality cannot Trump the state the
state code that you can have more
stringent standard but you can't say we
don't want that okay so this is
definitely an enhancement of the overall
process okay thank you anyone else
personent Gart and the brown just quick
question was did you say International
thises is international codes that we're
adopting yes some of them are
international meaning the United States
and whoever chooses to go along with us
thank
you uh thank you madam chair so for
representative Simon from from the
subcommittee so it is possible that 10
municipalities could have a slightly
different code than the state code or 20
municipalities or
30 technically all of the
municipalities yeah it would have to be
an amendment to a specific code that has
already been adopted by the building
code review board and subsequently
passed through us so we would have to
vote on that but yes they can they can
amend that to make it a little bit more
restrictive if they want to um but it
stringent yes more stringent sorry thank
you for the clarification um yes but it
would still keep it within the same code
okay and followup follow so did you get
a feeling in subcommittee
that this process might control
so much inconsistency throughout the
state that there might be 100
municipalities with a different code
because of this
process yes okay representative Shu and
then laus thank you madam chair um I do
have I guess You' call it a question for
representative Simon is this similar to
from time to time in my town we vote on
updating our zoning codes and it will
state to conform with State Standards is
that the idea the same thing with
this no well the
it's it wouldn't be to conform with
State Standards because the State
Building Code applies it would be to
make a special distinction for Penbrook
state although if if a 100 or 200 towns
start adopting the same Amendment
there's a darn good chance it should
apply to the rest of the state but I
believe we heard that there were five
towns that had actually submitted
amendments which is a pretty tiny number
represent laus yeah and this might um
help with I don't know U represent
Brown's thing um my understanding of the
history and please anybody who's been
here longer correct me if I'm wrong is
that there one time there was no State
Building Code and every town could adopt
their own set of rules on building and
um so when the uh State Building Code
was adopted instead of uh just saying
towns have no flexibility
whatsoever um the decision was made to
allow them in some controlled process to
have their own amendments to the code
for whatever the local circumstances are
now while I might not like that actually
if we're going to have the state only
code I'd rather not have the local towns
make it more restrictive I still see
this as an improvement I'm going to
support it because at least it makes the
process regularizes it U makes it have
to go through official process there's
some review that they're not just
completely you know off thewall on what
they're doing and it keeps it all in one
place so at least people who are in the
trades and Builders can can figure out
what's going
ones Simon yeah um I was going to
mention that as well representative
Brown you we've talked about making it
more restrictive but the initial concern
was that they were dealing with code
that was 10 Cycles behind or five Cycles
behind and and the and so they were
running into issues with insurance
coverage and things of that nature the
other way that it helps to the question
that you were asking before is um even
though they have made these amendments
as representative leus just said they'll
all be locatable in one spot so so we so
the state knows what those are Builders
can go and find out what those those are
they're not going to show up on site and
have the the local um code guy basically
just throw something at them without
them having any ability to go verified
whether that's gone through the legal
process um so that becomes so you can
still fight that sort of thing but it
comes very expensive for the Builder for
the client um because now you've got to
take actual legal action this would this
would simplify that process and allow
them to find those codes um that have
gone through the legal process much more
easily thank thank you both
okay anyone
else okay the motion is ought to pass on
Senate Bill 437 by representative Simon
and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative melin yes representative
Dolan yes representative gearhard yes
clerk votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative G yes
representative Smith yes representative
maputi yes and the chair yes 20a Zer
name okay motion passes 20 is there any
objection to
consent seeing none we'll put it on
Senate Bill
372 rep representative
G thank you madam chair I have an
amendment which actually came to us from
the Senate Senator Murphy had uh drafted
the amendment and I got it changed to a
house Amendment and you should all have
it in front of you it's
7h and I move a to pass on the
amendment is there a
second
right gr do you wish to speak to your
anyone else comments questions represent
gold do you have more well I I just was
going to say that all the amendment does
is to increase um increase the
apprentices to two that a plumber is
allowed from one and uh fixed some
language that made it sound like it was
so I'd like to mention that it still
doesn't affect the uh federal labor
apprenticeship program and I would
imagine that all of the larger companies
that are going to be going for federal
contracts will be complying with the
requirements of that uh
program but the smaller
businesses that have enough enough to do
keeping up with the the local work will
be able to have two app two
apprenticeships which will
else
okay the motion is to adopt Amendment
1577 to Senate Bill 372 and the clerk
can call the
role represent Simon yes represent lakas
yes representative Bailey yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Dolan yes
representative Gard yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative gr yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
represent
gold uh Madam chair I'd like to move
ought to pass with
Amendment uh on Senate Bill 372 there a
second second by represent of
discussion okay that case the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment on Senate
Bill 372 and the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Melvin yes
representative Dolan yes representative
gearhard yes clerk votes yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative gold yes
representative Smith yes yes
representative man py yes and the chair
yes 2 a0 N okay motion passes 20 to Z
any objections to
consent seeing none we'll put it on
consent and representative G you'll have
a committee report
today I'll have it to you this evening
all right thank
there Ben a bill three 69 representative
Simon you have that one
yes yes Madam chair I would like to move
Amendment uh
second
okay sign you wish to speak to it um
yeah so the amendment is very simple um
in the original bill it made it sound
like we were going to leave um public
comment open um like verbal testimony
open for 10 days which seemed uh
unworkable uh that people would be able
to show up for 10 days and and testify
verbally uh so this just splits up um
chapter 7 and chapter 8 into basically
saying that you can give spoken comment
um and that the written testimony will
be open for submission it was 7 Days uh
we changed it to 10 days because that's
the general practice
um with uh the ability to submit written
testimony um so we felt like maybe that
was not the part uh to speed up um but
to allow the public ample time um we
sped up some of the processes the the
regular Bill speeds up some of the
processes and the rest of uh rest of the
uh process sorry for using the same word
four times um but it only changes it to
10 days here so that was the amendment
okay represent Brown you wish to comment
amendment okay the motion is to adopt
Amendment 1575 to Senate Bill 369 the
clerk can call the role representative
Simon yes representative lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Melvin yes representative Dolan yes
representative gearhard yes clerk votes
yes representative voyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
sht yes representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative gold yes
representative Smith yes representative
Z represent
Simon thank you madam chair I would like
to move a to pass with
Amendment I'll second okay
should speak to your motion uh yeah this
was a bill that we passed last year but
the governor had some concerns uh with
it as it was written last year so uh
this bill has addressed that we believe
it's addressed those concerns um having
to deal with special exceptions for
emergency hearings and disciplinary
remedial proceedings things of that
nature um so we've we've created some
exceptions uh for those issues we think
it'll be agreeable to the governor at
I believe that's representative Simon
explained it well okay anyone else
questions
comments all right seeing none the
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
on Senate Bill 369 and the clerk can
call the
all representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey yes representative Melvin yes
representative Dolan yes representative
geard clerk votes yes representative
Boyd yes representative Brown yes
representative gr yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes representative
Schultz yes representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative G yes representative
Smith yes representative manuti yes and
the chair yes 20a Zer a all
right motion passes 20 to
zero um
consent all right seeing none we'll put
consent
okay and representative groa you've got
the next last two yes I'd like to
move um amendment
155h to Senate Bill
okay and I'll second
this the amendment um as a definition
for Manufacturing Housing dispute
resolutions um which was not in the
original Bill and would be necessary
resolutions
okay I don't think I have this amendment
either okay I've got
it
you um I don't
remember I think it I read it last night
she sent I think it was representative
Maguire
this that's the definition right it adds
the definition of manufactured housing
dispute resolution which would otherwise
have been repealed by section two and
um which is necessary because somebody's
resolution any any as I understand it oh
sorry gu yeah as I understand does this
uh then give the Authority for that R
making to the office now rather than any
board yes yeah that was in the original
yeah yeah thank
you
um any other questions concerns
represent Brown thank you madam chair
does
it replaces all of section one in the
mean
basically yes yeah it it basically
replaces section one by adding a
sentence to the paragraph in Roman two
never mind thank you thank you
representative goalie
helpful all
comments
okay in that case the motion is to adopt
Amendment 1555 H to Senate Bill 306 and
the clerk call the role representative
Simon yes representative lakas yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Melvin yes representative Dolan yes
representative Gard yes vot yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Brown yes representative groda yes
representative Schmid yes representative
goalie yes representative sht yes
representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative
yes representative Smith yes
representative Manti yes and the chair
yes 2809 all right we have adopted the
amendment representative
gold um excuse me that's okay I move
that's right a of pass with amendment to
Senate Bill
306 okay is there a
second second second by represent
goalie all right any further discussion
comments questions
well I could add that Senate Bill 306
allows the state to have its own
resolution
um dispute resolution process as opposed
to allowing it to be done on the HUD
level so by adopting the amendment we
have made it incompliant with HUD and
therefore we can establish our own State
process and I will I'd like to add that
we have heard not just on this bill but
on many other cases that nobody wants to
deal with the the federal HUD
regulations so they really want to have
process any other comments questions
goie all right that case the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment on Senate
Bill 306 and the clerk can call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Dolan yes representative gearhard clerk
votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative Brown yes representative
gr yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Schultz yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
Manti yes in the chair yes 2 a0 N all
right motion passes
20 is is there any objection to
consent right seeing none put that on
consent all right finally sen Bill
485 represent broa yes thank you um
thank you Madame chair so when the
subcommittee met on Senate Bill 485 you
might remember that we were to compare
it to the bill that we had passed
earlier and that the house had passed
earlier that had been Pro sponsored by
um representative Brown
um and I believe that number was House
Bill
1395 1385 sorry so the committee wanted
to make sure that what was in Senate
Bill 485 that was different from Senate
Bill 4 13 from House Bill
1385 would be um considered so we wrote
the amendment and the part that was
unique to Senate Bill 485 was the
digitally verifiable licenses and the
amendment is 1517 2024
however the um I heard from both um
director Courtney and I spoke with
commissioner goule this
morning that digitally verifiable
licenses are much more complicated than
one would have originally
thought and we don't know what the cost
would be and there's only one state
that's doing this and it requires
accessibility or data interface with
other states to
know what their credentialing
is so the long story short is I'm going
to move interim study on Senate Bill
485 until we
understand we have a better
clarification as to what's involved
second second by representative
Schmidt all right representative Schmidt
motion you're recognizing me uh I I
think that there's some issues here uh
I'm going to ask representative gr to
right off the bat what is the other
state that that is I don't know I'm
sorry I don't know no no it would be
helpful to find that out but there there
are some is isues here that are that
need to be clarified before we can go
forward maybe it's a good idea I'm not
sure too many unanswered question so
let's let's do interim study okay
represent leus thank you yeah I'm not
going to oppose interim study I'm just
wondering what is it that this bill
intended to do that wasn't covered by
the house
bill so the the the house bill and the
Senate Bill are both trying to assist in
the uh licensing of the mil of military
folk and so in the the the person that
presented this part of the amendment you
might remember is is someone who owns a
company that does
this so there was some concern that they
may be the only company that do this and
we don't have and we certainly wouldn't
sign up with only one company
and therefore what are the requirements
and it's a feel that we are not
currently this is sort of Cutting Edge
computer technology software technology
and we are not on The Cutting Edge of
that follow up um so so is it that
really the only thing this was intended
to add beyond the house bill was the
digital correct thank you
yes representative Brown um I think
maybe I don't know thank you Madame
chair my
apologies I'm so recuperating from my
Senate
testimony you're lucky you got out of
there alive you have not done that
before um I I think on the amendment on
line
25 sorry line 23 new paragraph Yes yes I
see that I think
that we did want that
to be changed uh in 1385 but we didn't
do it because we were too short of time
so we may have to put what is on line 25
and 26 in 1385 as an amendment on the
Senate side no no because we still have
if I'm not correct this is not an early
bill so if you want me to draft an
amendment that only that basically
eliminates par section one and talks
about about we do need something we we
had talked about section
two which is to allow
um the military education and the MOs
related issue addressed and we also
wanted to um adopt that all boards not
only those that are under
oplc complete the ru making requirement
so if the commiss if the committee
wishes is I can submit an amendment and
bring it next week for section two only
and we deal with digitally verifiable
licenses separately at a later time does
that is that amable to the committee so
the if I understand you correctly you're
suggesting
that you incl include section two which
is getting each board to decide
what uh military occupation is related
to their
board which we've been trying to do for
several years and haven't had a lot of
success and it's not in 1385 it's not in
1385 so this would be a charge to the
boards
to do some of this work correct so if if
if the committee agrees what the
amendment would look like is amend the
bill Title by replacing it with the
following and we would just jump
automatically to line
18 where we talk about training
education and service and we would leave
out paragraph
one
okay repres blackis uh just a note since
you notice possible continuing uh exec
tomorrow if OLS could get it in time we
could even do it
possibility well I could just pit down
there quickly and Peter P down there and
get that done okay all
right thank you representative laus this
will be
postponed
to
uh the previously posted executive
session for
tomorrow we have completed all of the
other
bills um so represent broa is
is before we decide go away and not do
that is there any further discussion on
this bill before we uh come up with the
amendment that we hope we will adopt
tomorrow I'd like to say we've been
trying to get the boards to report on
these kinds of requirements for years
again yeah okay all right and for
scheduling purposes commit committee we
have three public hearings
tomorrow on which are the last of our
Senate
bills and I'm planning an a final
executive session for the bills that are
still in
subcommittee and those three
on either the 7eventh or the eth of
March of may excuse me
and other than that thank you all for
surviving uh Madam chair if if I might
could this the folks that voted
uh uh against the itl for 439 if you'd
all give me a minute of your time to
right okay thank you
all we
done so thought you already closed I did
this committee report I did not include
the language you said about the larger
businesses that's fine that's fine
be okay I'll turn to S thank you you
might want to put a big X on the other
you
e